this idea that you're gonna be a solo
premier outsource or work for hours or
part-time you guys try to do the
part-time thing you will have full-time
problems don't talk to strangers
strangers got everything you want man
[Music]
everything you want a stranger's got it
your friends ain't got nothing for
people are people like me and you work
hard need motivation watch the top ten
would believe nation what's that belief
nation at seven my one word is believe
and I believe in you I believe you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
and I want you to find it embrace it and
use it to make a difference so let's get
your motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from a man who went
from coming out of a drug rehab center
at age 25 becoming a millionaire five
years later and today owning half a
billion dollars plus in real estate is
Grant Cardone and here's my take on his
top ten rules of success volume six
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one maximize your life if you're not
gonna work like a 10-hour day as a short
day for me I hear more people promoting
this for our idea okay like Tim Ferriss
I just call him out right now it is
complete bunk in this complete [ __ ]
you cannot skit you cannot outsource
everything this idea that you're gonna
be a solopreneur
outsource or work for hours or part-time
you guys try to do the part-time thing
you will have full-time problems forever
for the end of you to the end of your
life not only will you have problems cuz
you're selfish if you're trying to do a
4-hour work week you're selfish you're
thinking only about yourself if you
don't scale and hire people you are also
selfish you're trying to manage money
rather than saying hey I have a great
message like you you have an obligation
man to get out there and help people so
I don't know how to do ten hours I know
how to I know I need six to seven maybe
eight hours of sleep a day the question
is how am I gonna best utilize my other
16 hours with my family as a father as a
community leader as somebody that's
interested in changing the conditions
around me right and how can I use that
phone to maximize those 16 hours and how
can I spend time with my kids that
actually adds value to my business right
how can I create a studio so me and my
wife can work together on Wednesdays
like everything that we do here is about
my life so that I'm dropping stuff into
my life bucket my work gets dropped in
here so it's like everything I did I go
on a trip I go look at real estate I do
an interview I set up a house with in
Deer Valley for a month I have people
come over investors I look at real
estate everything is basically I'm um
what is it you're charting yeah exactly
inside a soup right I'm making a meal
called my life and that's what I would
tell people to do quit thinking about
how little you can do and start thinking
about how much how much how many
different things gonna do in the same
day
rule number two invest in yourself I'm
gonna save money this is what you hear
if you look on the internet how do I
make money first thing you got to do is
you got
save money what do you hear the
politicians say the middle class I'm
here to save it what if there is no
middle class and it was just made up to
keep the people civil CCC see that
that's how you're gonna play this game
you got to be available people have to
know you don't talk to strangers
strangers got everything you want man
everything you want a stranger's got it
your friends ain't got nothing right if
it's up to your friends that you're done
like all my friends are broke I'm 25
years old everybody around me was broke
okay
my momma was scared every time my momma
Tuesday Tuesday she's clipping coupons
that was some reason to get the
newspaper the coupons are coming she
would sit there and clip a man she had
him in the little box I learned that for
you for 16 years I watched my mom do
that for 16 years my mom would tell me
hey grant turn those lights up turn
those lights up me and my twin brother
turn those lights off from across the
house she could hear me walk out of my
bedroom 75 feet away say turn those damn
lights off I told you okay twin brothers
okay I'm 16 years old my twin brother my
mom said when you guys go pee do it
together
saves water saves water right okay when
my mom fed me cuz mama I had a great mom
I'm completely how many of you had great
parents give you give your parents great
aunt huh good hey just because they were
great payers doesn't mean they weren't
confused right because my mama was
confused man my mom did not know how to
make money she had no education she had
no ability she had never held a job she
did not know how to get money so what
she had to do was protect a little bit
of money she had Celebi sold she was
sold on conservation reduce risk
don't spend contract protected defended
you understand diversified have a lot of
little bets all over the place okay lots
a little bit you should never have a lot
of bets all over the place until you're
extremely wealthy when you're trying to
get wealthy you want to literally you
want to go all-in and it not be a bet
you need to know the space so well that
you're like I know for sure this is
going to work
what do you know we'll pay you every
time for sure yeah rule number three
make decisions quickly make decisions
quickly so that I can sell things
quickly because if you do it if you do
it if you do it a certain way you give
yourself permission to ask other people
to do the same thing
it's built in ethics at the end of the
last year on December the four thirteen
to fourteen captain Ryan's in a row I
said dude we're gonna by playing by the
end of the year okay okay I'm gonna wipe
out my tax bill
i'ma buy a damn plane and we're gonna
wipe it out okay I bought a plane in
less than nine days
brand-new plane in nine days the guy
Gulfstream says dude nobody does this
most people take nine months some people
take nine years the nine days both plane
bought it shopped it bought it closed it
he's like nobody doesn't stick
ridiculous huge purchase big purchase
typically a very long cycle a lot a lot
of shopping guarantee of that decision
that quickly would make me a lot of
money
you understand why I saw I make
decisions man so what do I expect you
guys to make decisions the same way I
spent 50 million bucks in freaking 90
minutes and you guys take freaking nine
months to spend six grand
make decisions quick make decisions as
fast as you can stay certain you can get
new money everybody agree see when I do
that in my own life I could press you to
do the same thing I've given myself
permission and in this universe giving
myself permission to push people to do
things faster if you take a long time to
do things your bar will then be allowed
to take a long time to do things you
shop a second place a third plate the
fourth place the fifth place a sixth
place guess what they will - you got to
get a best deal cuz your daddy taught
you to get a good deal never be taking
advantage up shop - in three places get
your best discount it's gotta be on sale
don't guess what every customer you have
is gonna what give me a deal man give me
a deal man give me a deal man ok
your worst customers are the ones you
give the best deal - never can make them
happen
they want something Oh give me something
extra give me something else - the mooch
never satisfied right or wrong
did you guys are muchas you got some
muchas just be honest man you can't fix
what you deny your mooch there gonna be
a mooch they're cheap they're gonna be
cheap
you're cheap they're gonna be cheap you
take a long time they're gonna take a
long time you shop four or five places
they're gonna do the same thing you need
more information they're gonna do the
same thing you got to have your wife and
pop they're gonna do the same thing rule
number four scale everybody's trying to
go out there and not sell you guys are
all trying like I'm gonna I'm gonna be
talented talent does not win I know a
whole bunch of guys less talented than
me that beat me for years they beat me
because they got exposure in the market
point day some of those names you just
in different sectors in real estate okay
I got it there's a group that they went
out and bought 140,000 units you know I
got 4500 they're not as good they they
make take a lot of shortcuts they don't
take care of the tenant as well as I do
but they thought way bigger than I did
so you know what I'm saying like it's in
different spaces there was an automotive
space that I was in for years I was the
leader in the automotive space me and
another guy constantly combating right
he had a garbage product he sold for
less than I did he he scaled better than
I didn't he beat me at the scale game so
you can't see a lot of people say look
look man Steve Jobs started his business
in a garage the the I think Cadillacs
got a commercial where the Cadillac was
created in a garage who else Bill Gates
started his business in a garage Mark
Zuckerberg started Facebook in in a dorm
everybody's like oh my god man I can do
this from home none of those companies
got big when they stayed in the garage
of the dorm Marquis II didn't make it
until he moved to Silicon Valley and
built a team okay Google didn't become
Google until they had a campus in
Silicon Valley and they scaled to tens
of thousands of employees so you have to
scale to be great so would you say then
for the average entrepreneur out there
as they are as a grow their business
getting those sales they should
definitely be sending some of that
income aside you should you should be
source yeah you should not be thinking
about what you can
Vonn right I made eight grand this month
man all of its net profit all that money
should be reinvested in people so that
that's why people think incorrectly
that's why I always go back to this
argument about look the solopreneurs is
selfish
almost like a little selfish child right
I'm gonna go out I left my job I was
making 90 grand now I'm Anna me and Gary
Vaynerchuk had this conversation I was
making 90 grand now I'm gonna work for
myself and make 90 grand and Gary's like
well yeah the guy's better off the guys
better off working except for himself
for 90 grand then working for somebody
else and I'm like dude nobody's better
off working for 90 grand you can't live
on the honey grant not today ya know
anywhere in the America there's nowhere
in America you live in for 90 grand and
in Miami you're gonna have twelve
thousand dollars before taxes left over
at the end of the year if you don't shop
at Whole Foods so the point of that is
if you were working for ninety thousand
for a company and then you go work for
yourself for ninety thousand you should
be taking that money in buying a
secretary buying a receptionist buying
scale buying a sales team reinvesting
money you should not have any money left
over at ninety grant all of it should be
going to be poured back into the
business to scale out unless all you're
thinking about is yourself
right rule number five have an insane
work ethic
LeBron shows up this dude comes in 15
minutes before practice and LeBrons
gives him that look like hey dude what's
going on here he's like what do you mean
I'm 15 minutes early he's like should
have been here an hour ago and and and
when he says that to this dude the guy
knows LeBron's been there for two hours
so all I ask you to do is like here's
the guy probably the best that's ever
walked out on a basketball court
short of Michael Jordan
but both of them have one thing in
common they worked okay what about their
just their talent it was about their
work ethic people knew them for their
work ethic so just ask yourself this
week do people know you for your work
ethic for people or people like me you
work hard or people actually commenting
about you showing up early and staying
late because if they're not then you're
just you're just blending in with
everybody else's work ethic at the end
of the day talent will not win the game
if his work ethic that will win the game
so when I saw this I'm like here's a guy
top of his games got all the money you
could possibly he could never spend all
his money
impossible he'll be a billionaire okay
and he's showing up two hours early to
make sure he plays the game to make sure
he's in physical condition to make sure
that he can stay in the game long past
he doesn't even need it he's got all his
rings I got to tell you I was so
inspired by because I got a bunch of
partners I got guys that I do business
with I got one of them in particular
that I'm having some problems with he
told me man if I had your money dude I
would return he said there's took me
over and over and I hadn't been
listening to it enough to understand he
wants to go lay down okay you cannot run
what's that thing called you did can't
do an Iron Man with that attitude
no don't know why you'd want to do an
Iron Man
but I'll tell you what if you could do
an Ironman and then take that and add it
to your to your to your career to the
longevity of your career you know
because look it's gonna be five years
from now ten years from now it's gonna
be twenty years you're gonna look back
and say and the marketplace is gonna
reward whatever you do every day rule
number six be a fighter I'm in a lot of
battles every day that nobody sees I
mean these are some of these battles are
brutal man later like they like there's
some things it doesn't matter how many
people you have around you could have 85
employees another 150 some other place
you could be married have kids there are
so many things that a person if you're
in the game all the way you will have to
do by yourself you're gonna die by
yourself like it doesn't matter how many
people you get around do there are some
things you gotta you got to confront
your fears by yourself you got to
confront your doubts by yourself
like that's the stuff that I'm doing
every day so I'm stringing a lot of
futures I got a lot of games going on
all the time I got a lot of games I want
to win at half of my lose half out of my
win but I'm gonna fight like like I have
a tremendous I don't have the flight
fight or flight I have the fight I'm a
fighter I'm a fighter like I've really
trained the fighter who as I remember
being bullied as a kid and I didn't like
it
so you know I'm a fighter I'm in there
figuring out the fight like all this
stuff that I do all the time the webinar
I do one I've done three webinars in 22
days nobody's done them nobody's ever
done bang bang bang bang bang to two or
three the third one we sell like I mean
super successful these are best-selling
multi-million dollar webinars on out of
an idea while I'm doing that I'm gonna
go shading 160 million dollar sale a
hundred and twenty five million dollar
refinance a hundred and sixty million
dollar purchase flavored at our fourth
funded just like sure how do you do it
them
or you guys get going on the better
you're gonna like the game I'm telling
you your excuse man you want more
activity you want more threats
you don't want less you got slowed down
yo when you slow down the environment
becomes threatening when you speed up if
it comes your environment rule number
seven don't make dumb purchases this car
right here this rolls-royce Wraith with
freaking magic the magic astrological
zodiac sign built into the ceiling with
little sparkles dumbest damn thing you
could ever buy in your life is a big
expensive luxury car in fact okay in my
rant today I want to share with you one
of the things that I did smart in my
life was I never bought these exotic
cars that everybody seems to go out and
buy as soon as they make a little money
what I did was this I waited I waited
and I waited to ever do a dumb thing
like this number one of the dumbest
things ever bought my damn
okay I waited until number one I didn't
have to buy one and number two until it
didn't matter I just got my financial
statement in three months the first
three months of this year compared to
last year a double a double you
understand what a double is a double
means I can do stupid okay look once you
make enough money to where you can blow
four hundred and sixty one thousand
dollars and it don't matter then go do
it okay until then until then do not
waste your money I'm sorry this car was
only three hundred eighty four thousand
dollars I didn't want to exaggerate to
you but I think they added some stuff to
this bad boy so look until then until
then until then don't waste your money
on watches and cars and bring out Briony
suits okay it's ridiculous you guys that
are buying twelve hundred dollar shoes
stupid you guys are buying two hundred
thousand dollar cars stupid you guys
that are spending money on homes no
offense but just stupid you don't need
an expensive house you don't need a
Country Club yet what you need is paper
you need money baby
you need net worth you need passive
income you need flows baby flows and
flows and flows you don't need a Rolls
Royce rule number eight my personal
favorite embrace fear fear is the great
indicator sooner or later you will
experience fear when you start taking
new actions at new levels in fact if you
aren't then you're probably not doing
enough of the right things
fear isn't bad or something to be
avoided conversely it's something you
want to seek and then to embrace fear is
actually a sign that you're doing what
is needed to move in the right direction
what is fear anyway I mean really does
it even exist is it real
I know it feels real when you're
experiencing it but admit it
to the time what you fear doesn't even
occur fear for the most part is provoked
by emotions not rational thinking
chances are that when you were a child
you've found fear in irrational things
the boogeyman under the bed for example
adults have their own boogeymen the
unknown rejection failure fear of
success and on and on for example if
you're afraid to call a client then it's
that sound you should call that client
fear of speaking with the boss is an
indication you should march into his
office and ask for a moment of this time
everyone everyone experiences fear on
some level the fear doesn't just tell
you what to do it also tells you when to
do it
ask yourself what time is it at any
point in the day and the answer is
always the same the time is now the time
is always now and when you experience
fear it's a sign that the best time to
take action is that that very moment now
the only thing that will make a
difference in that moment of fear is
action failure comes in many forms it
occurs whether you act or you don't act
regardless of the outcome I would say
it's far preferable to fail while doing
something than to fail by over preparing
while someone else walks up and scoops
up your dreams fear is assigned to do
whatever it is you fear and do it
quickly
rule number 9 think big enough I grew up
in Lake Charles Louisiana for those who
viewed under my story and my dad my dad
was he had five kids wife he was
dedicated and committed to being the
provider for his family
like any of you or how many of you
provide for your family probably want to
do a good job at my dad wanted to do a
good job at so my dad died when I was 10
years old he had he had owned a life
insurance company he actually started a
life insurance company it was taken from
him him and a partner it was taken from
him at the age of I guess he was 42
years old 42 years always got five kids
he's got a wife to take care of and no
job how many been in transition before
yeah so 42 lotta obligation now starting
to move into the middle class 42 years
old he's got he's got twin boys coming
they didn't
- you know good Catholic family doing
the planning every five years we'd have
a baby so he was plant you could tell
like when I look back in my in his life
today there's a long answer to a short
question but like like you guys you guys
need to figure out your your why you're
gonna do whatever you're gonna do my dad
knew why he was gonna do what he was
going to do but my dad didn't think big
enough it's it's it's it's a it's a I
got two things for my dad one every day
he worked he was up early
he stayed late he's in transition
between 42 and 50 - he's in transition
in his life right he's having to go from
life insurance company big dream company
gets stolen away from him he's like what
am i doing right this is a story the
middle class right here this is called
gravity this is yesterday's Miami bridge
falling and everybody's like okay
believe that happened
structures fall folks so this is what I
learned from my dad my mom had to sell a
dream house that was paid for in cash my
dad bought a dream house a year and a
half before he got up before he died we
all went in celebrated oh my god this is
unbelievable this is crazy this is great
we made it to the middle class my dad
dies my mom has to sell the house a week
literally a week after my dad dies when
she should have been grieving she was
having to sell this dream house you
understand what I'm saying this is what
I learned when I was 10 years old man
life is short okay my dad didn't provide
he did he worked hard but he didn't have
enough because if he had enough my mom
would not have had to sell the dream
house everybody agree with that okay my
mom did not know how to produce new
income so my mom had to go into
conservation so when you ask me the
question how did you start I started
with the wrong data okay I started with
the wrong data and the data was hey life
is short something Bad's gonna happen
all that's true but if you could out
produce if you could produce enough
income you could start solving some of
these problems like indestructible
income and rule number ten the last one
before a very special bonus clip is
have fun
[Music]
never ever never never there
Wow what a mother's gonna do
Wow
horse attached disco tired
when you feel weak
if you like you just want to give up
what you got
many in a string the patient
[Music]
the curve
I've got a really special grant cardone
bonus clip on how to push power to power
that I think you're really gonna enjoy
but before that question today I want to
know which rule spoke to you more either
embrace fear or have an insane work
ethic let me know in the comments below
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
and enjoy the bonus clip
my daddy told me dr. Kara our local
doctor he was the most successful doctor
in the in uh we knew both the most
successful doctors dr. care dr. Morin
right and dr. care was at the house in
there drinking martinis and like that I
am and do that too
my dream martini that would be James
Bond right
and dr. chair came up to me and says
give me a dollar I had a dollar too he's
like give me that dollar I ain't giving
you a dollar my daddy said never deny a
man in power never deny a man in power
okay
never talk poorly about somebody in
power push power to power that's a good
investment folks okay if you take your
notes write this down push power to
power people that are doing good things
people that are making a difference
people that are out there push power to
power and ignore everyone else we don't
help people that have nothing I'm
telling you right now I do not help
people that have nothing I had I help
people that have something and want to
make it more I'm not talking about money
right now if somebody thinks they have
nothing I'm not helping that person if
they think they have nothing I can't
help them if you think you have
something and that you're not broke I
can help
cuz you're not broke okay this slide you
tell yourself about I don't have any
money I don't have any money you have
something man you got commitment
you got creativity you can't bankrupt
guy like me now you gonna take all my
money I get asked this all the time man
what would you do without what would you
do if somebody took all your money ain't
nobody gonna take all my money okay
nobody can take all my money nobody
thinks big enough you can't steal all my
money dude a thief never thinks big
enough that's why he steals a thief
steals less than he could have made
honestly okay but if I didn't have any
money today take away everything
whatever that means everything is I'm
still left with what I'm Grant Cardone
I got courage I have creativity most of
the things that matter okay I'm willing
to come off of a damn whatever that
thing is the Box I got guts I'm willing
to be bold right how many of you have
those things how many of you got courage
how many of you got creativity how many
of you got guts how many of you got
dreams if you tell yourself a story long
enough you start to believe it won't you
believe it you act like it I have Tulsa
what a wail out of handcuffed lightning
though Thunder in jail now you know I'm
bad over the last week I murdered a rock
into the stone hospitalized a brick I'm
so mean I make medicine sick the
fundamental key to success he's it can
take between eighteen and two hundred
and fifty-four days of taking action for
a new habit to stick I've created a new
course called 250 for confidence or
every single day for 250 four days I
will be sending you a video between 30
seconds and 5 minutes long that you
start your morning with around making
you feel confident it's absolutely free
check out the link in the description
below to get access